je vais donner la parole immédiatement
au président philippe bas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président ma question
concerne la justice et je tenais à
l'adresser au premier ministre parce que
dans la situation critique de nos
finances publiques lui seul dispose
encore de quelques clés pour amorcer un
redressement
pas une semaine ne se passe sans que des
prévenus soient libérés faute d'avoir pu
être présentés à temps un juge
nos prisons sont saturés certaines
d'entre elles sont même vétustes nos
tribunaux sont emboliser aussi bien au
civil qu'au pénal en raison de
l'aggravation de la délinquance les
frais de justice ne sont pas payés en
temps utile
nos lois ne cesse d'alourdir les charges
qui pèsent sur les tribunaux et un
certain nombre d'entre elles sont
inappliquée au point d'être devenu
virtuel
c'est le cas par exemple de la loi sur
la contrainte pénale faute de moyens les
effectifs de magistrats et greffiers
votée par le parlement ne sont pas
pourvus dans ces conditions je sais que
le garde des sceaux partage ce
diagnostic
un sursaut est indispensable ma question
est est ce que le gouvernement est
décidé à amorcer ce redressement
nécessaire malgré le peu de temps qui
lui reste pour agir pour vous répondre
la parole est monsieur le garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
jean jacques urvoas sauver la parole oui
merci monsieur le président
je ne peux pas dire autre chose que ce
qu'a dit ping base sur le constat
j'aime d'ailleurs relie à 5 mois en
prenant cette responsabilité utiliser un
terme qui a choqué j'avais dit que
c'était une institution qui était en
voie de clochardisation
le mot a choqué il n'aurait pas dû
choquer c'est la réalité qui était
choquant et voilà pourquoi ce jeudi en
voie de clochardisation parce que c'est
un risque que je pèse et c'est un combat
auquel invite l'assemblée nationale le
sénat
l'ensemble des collectivités évidemment
l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics ce
message est entendu monsieur le
président vous le savez depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois tout le monde
premier ministre a dit le président de
la république a répété que beaucoup
avaient déjà été fait parce que je ne
suis que d'accord sur votre constat sur
les réponses nous avons déjà commencé à
répondre depuis quatre ans je l' ai déjà
dit dans cette assemblée nous avons créé
beaucoup de postes il y a aujourd'hui à
l'école nationale de la magistrature
plus de postes que de magistrats qu'il
n'y en a jamais eu dans l'école
nationale de l'administration
pénitentiaire à agen il à 868
surveillants de prison qui sont en
formation à l'école nationale des
greffes à dijon il ya la plus grande
promotion à l'école de la pjj à roubaix
il ya la plus grande promotion donc
beaucoup a été fait mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut continuer l'effort
les chiffres sont connus maintenant pour
2010 est monsieur le président puisqu'il
vaut être évoqué tout à l'heure dans le
débat dans l'occasion de dire vous aurez
le budget de la justice l'année
prochaine est un très bon budget et je
suis très fier d'être le ministre de la
justice qui va enregistré la progression
la plus forte depuis 2012
au total il va y avoir plus de 4,6 pour
cent d'augmentation 300 millions de plus
il va donc avoir un budget qui va
atteindre 6 milliards 9
parce que vous savez comme moi monsieur
le président que c'est pas huit
milliards qu'il faut évoquer mes 6
milliards 6 c'était le concept que c'est
orcas pension 300 millions de plus
monsieur le président c'est considérable
au regard de la modestie du besoin et
donc il faut continuer j'espère que les
années qui suivront vont continuer cette
progression depuis 2012
nous avons fait progresser le ministère
de la justice de 14%
jamais aucun gouvernement ne l'avait
fait c'est beaucoup mais maintenant il
faut parler vrai 10 et michel rocard
il faut agir juste nous allons agir
juste en dépensant à bon escient mais
nous verrons dans le débat avec le
parlement et singulièrement avec le
sénat la façon dont ce milliard seront
répartis de mon point de vue
ce n'est pas maintenant sur les
créations de poste où il faut faire
prendre et l'effort mais sur les
juridictions puisque c'est là que le
besoin
monsieur le président philippe bas nous
entendons ce nouveau discours pendant
trois ans et demi le verbe un verbe haut
à remplacer l'action et cette pratique
gouvernementale a fortement entamé votre
crédit monsieur le ministre au moment où
vous prenez vos fonctions
l'impasse dans laquelle madame taubira
nous a conduits à profondément atteint
le service public de la justice
vous avez commencé par l'abandon du
programme de création de 23 mille places
en prison vous avez prétendu remplacer
les courtes peines par des peines de
contraintes pénale faute de moyens elles
ne sont pas mises en oeuvre
et aujourd'hui vous improvisé avec des
mesurettes le divorce sans le juge 4
millions d'économies pour la justice
entre 50 à 80 millions de dépenses pour
les couples car il faudra désormais deux
avocats cette improvisation n'est pas
acceptable